do you want to learn how to grow rice
more sustainably attend a kana meeting
with extension officers in your area to
select the best rice variety and create
a crop calendar for the season extension
officers will show you how to use water
more efficiently and appoint a water
controller farmers lose approximately 10
to 20 percent of their rice harvests due
to pests and diseases every year to
prevent this
use seeds of the most adapted rice
varieties for the area and season
available at the one stop super
the rice research and development
institute recommends these varieties for
the macha season the rice research and
development institute recommends these
varieties for the yala season
after land preparation
request laser leveling through your
extension officer to improve water
efficiency and yield in your fields
[Music]
next form buns and plaster to hold water
for every season
make sure a field water tube is placed
in the field to monitor the water level
you can save water for this season and
next if you plant at the beginning of
the rainy macha season the second week
of october instead of the fourth week
instead of broadcasting that uses up to
100 kilograms per hectare of seeds use
improved rice planting methods compared
to broadcasting parachuting and line
seeding reduces seed requirements by 75
transplanting allows 12.5 percent higher
yields than broadcasting and saves money
if you can establish a nursery
use the parachute method or
transplanting machines
after 12 to 18 days parachute plantlets
in the field trays can be reused for
four seasons if your plot is at least
0.2 hectares you can request a motorized
transplanting service from the one-stop
super if you don't have time to
establish and protect a nursery you can
rent a lined seeder drum seeder for
direct seeding
manage weed for the first 30 days for
rice transplanted with a motorized paddy
transplanter use a motorized paddy
weeder
[Music]
for rye seeded with the drum seeder use
a manual kono weeder to control weeds in
between rows for advice on other weed
management practices ask experts at your
local crop clinic irrigate the field to
five centimeters above the surface level
and allow the field to drain until water
level goes below 15 centimeters
this will take around seven to ten days
depending on the soil type
[Music]
irrigate when the water is 15
centimeters below the surface level and
when you see weeds
one week after flowering irrigate when
the water level is 15 centimeters below
the surface level and when you see weeds
two weeks after flowering maintain the
water level zero to five centimeters
above the surface level
two weeks before harvesting allow fields
to drain gradually
[Music]
a 3.5 month variety that has the right
moisture level of
20-25
is ready for harvest at week 12.
at the one stop super you can receive
free services for grain moisture
measurements that reduce shuttering and
grain damages
[Music]
after harvest keep straw on your field
it is important to dry patty before
storing mobile patty drying is an
efficient and economical way to dry
padding
find out more about fao's approach to
climate smart crop production
[Music]
you